[Musique]
pas de concert consacré à beethoven
cinquième symphonie le compositeur
allemand est au coeur de ces nouveaux
concerts pédagogiques de la pms q comme
son concerto pour violon en ré majeur
c'est un concerto absolument magnifique
d'une part qui permet de mettre en
valeur lors qu'être la soliste
parce que aussi c'est un une musique qui
est un petit peu universel au même titre
que bach que mozart et beethoven
si on demande à un public non averti de
citer un nom de compositeur il ya de
fortes chances pour qu'il cite beethoven
mozart bach
une oeuvre qui fait vraiment partie du
répertoire ce camp parce que ils peuvent
avoir accès à ce répertoire là et puis
en fait
eh ben c'est petit à petit les choses se
font les enfants reviennent ils ont une
culture musicale et après c'est un
chemin qui est tracé cette année près de
4000 enfants assisteront à ces concerts
pédagogiques 45 minutes de musique
pourront aussi découvrir les instruments
et ans d'histoire de géographie et d'art
travailler en amont dans les écoles on
prépare un dossier pédagogique très très
fouillée très travaillé avec le chef
d'orchestre là la soliste et nous mêmes
les enseignantes ont ce dossier et en
plus maintenant avec les tableaux pédago
pédagogique ils peuvent écouter la
musique ils peuvent passer des
enregistrements ou envoient un orchestre
un concert que les enfants pourront
revivre en ami à les solistes de la
ville durs seront à nouveau sur la scène
de la mairie samedi 16 mars accompagné
des maîtrises de trappes et de
rambouillet
[Musique]